I'm here today going to play Google feud
where I guess the top search things in
Google I will be looking at different
categories and then I will be guessing
what are the most searched google
Curie's I would say I'm fairly in chin
with the internet I like to Google
myself sometimes see what I'm up to
not very much let's play google feud the
Windy City yeah I got that correct there
it is 10,000 the windy mill the windy
the windy too windy the windy windy the
windy the windy one other windy windy
the windy the windy people nope that's
two x's what other teams we put after
windy the windy the windy music note
three X's these are the answers the
windy Apple what the is the windy Apple
the Windy City assassin so I'm guessing
that's probably a serial killer or
something which is a great name the
Windy City assassin the windy road the
one oh it's not just when it's windy
that makes so much more sense
how does Google autocomplete this query
chocolate flavored chocolate ice cream
no one's googling chocolate flavored ice
cream okay wait I got to think of the
person that is googling a thing so they
don't need to Google chocolate flavored
ice cream because they already know what
that is chocolate flavored Oreos okay
I'm gonna do what not because I thought
of it because this is what I think of
the Internet let's just make that really
clear
mommy dad turn off this video condoms no
no it sounds like a grave coffee beer
why can I think of any of these things I
think my mom is crazy
that's that's not one of them okay drunk
two x's Wow okay what do people search
by the one I think my mom is a serial
killer three X's okay like I've seen the
answers now a lot eased it make sense I
think my mom is gay I don't think my mom
is I think my mom is a superhero very
sweet that's not possibly true though
because superheroes aren't real there's
only two positive ones which is being a
superhero an amazing and amazing being
the this
I find that set because you know what my
mom is amazing
Thomas okay Thomas in know Thomas Adams
I put atoms and with one D and then I
put atoms with two DS and neither of
them oh wait I have to think of like
popular people online
John I think is like they're not gonna
Google Thomas Adams he's not popular
it's such a dork
Oh Thomas Jefferson's probably not what
either is it but Thomas Sanders I've
gotten zero right in this whole game so
far what is the address of the White
House the one what is the address of
Donald Trump
that's not one I'm interesting I was
very confident that one such is life it
was the celebrity that creepy guys I'd
want to like send their like dirty socks
to Jennifer Lawrence no the president no
pup
what is that where I am the North Pole
Santa Claus no last week probably a
child know how to draw a circle I guess
no one has Google that cartoon I want to
know how to keep draw a cartoon I can't
believe that's not in the top ten how to
dry dog I'll never get it again how to
draw a cat nope no one asks that I'm
drunk at how did Turkey beat cat I think
it's a very fun game we all use Google
so you would think you'd be familiar
with the searching habits of other
people but I guess that the other day
you just kind of know your own starting
habits I do not have the same
consciousness as the internet my brain
does not work and I would also be
garbage at family feud
if my family had decided to do a family
feud I would have been removed from my
family and replaced with someone else
[Music]
you